the rel
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones in
house of the dragon update video in this
video i will show you why i think we
might see the first season of house of
the dragon a lot sooner than we think
now as you all know hbo is developing
another game of thrones show based on
george rr martin's fire in blood vol 1.
the dance of dragons a true telling by
grand maester monken being a history of
the war of targaryen succession between
the princess frenera and aegon second of
his name that nearly destroyed the realm
the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
in house of the dragon we will see what
happened during the dance of dragons in
fact we have already seen glimpses of
this in hbo max's first official teaser
for the show that was released a little
over a week ago i'm assuming all of you
have seen that by now what i found
really interesting about that teaser
trailer was the fact that hbo released
it so soon i believe this might indicate
we will see the first season of house of
the dragon in only a few months from now
let me show you what i mean
when you look at all of the release
dates for game of thrones you will see
that nearly every season was released
during the month of april as a matter of
fact six out of the eight seasons of
game of thrones was released in april
that led me to believe this is when we
will also see house of the dragon i
thought this made the most sense since
this is when hbo would always release
their seasons of game of thrones however
that was until hbo released their first
teaser for house of the dragon on
october 5th this made me go back and
look at all of the first official
teasers for each of the seasons of game
of thrones i wanted to see how many days
went by from when hbo would release a
teaser to when they would release the
first episode of that upcoming season i
think this will give us a better idea of
when we can actually expect to see house
of the dragon's first season now if i
have done my calculations correctly i
think we only have about 118 days until
the new season will air on hbo max again
let me show you what i mean
the very first thing hbo ever released
in relation to game of thrones was their
first preview video the raven this was
actually the very first video they ever
released on their official game of
thrones youtube channel
it was uploaded on january 10th of 2011.
that was 97 days before hbo released the
first episode of game of thrones now let
me show you what they did for the second
season the very first teaser they
released for the second season of game
of thrones was on september 30th of
2011.
[Applause]
that was 184 days before the first
episode of the second season aired on
hbo now let me show you what they did
for season 3. the very first teaser they
released for the third season of game of
thrones was on november 18th of 2012.
the great war is between death and life
ice and fire
that was 133 days before they aired the
first episode of season 3 on hbo now
let's see what they did for season 4.
the very first teaser they released for
season 4 was on january 10th of 2014
that was 86 days before they aired the
first episode of season four on hbo now
let's see what they did for season five
this was actually much shorter the very
first teaser for season five was
released on february 27 of 2015.
you spent your life
convincing 90 clans to come together for
the first time in history
thens and horned foots
the ice river clans even the giants that
was only 44 days before the first
episode of season five aired on hbo
now let's have a look at season six the
first official teaser for game of
thrones season six was uploaded on
december 3rd of 2015
[Music]
we watch
we listen
and we remember
that was 143 days before the first
episode aired on hbo
now let's have a look at season 7. the
first official teaser for game of
thrones season 7 was uploaded on march
9th of 2017
i know what my father was
what he did
that was 129 days before season seven's
first episode aired on hbo now the final
season of game of thrones had the same
number of days go by from when they
released the first teaser to when they
released the first episode for that
season
so some of you might be thinking what do
all these numbers mean well this means
that when hbo releases their first
official teaser for an upcoming season
of game of thrones they will wait 118
days on average before they release the
first episode for that new season now
what does that mean for house of the
dragon well when you consider the first
house of the dragon teaser was released
on october 5th that could mean the first
season will begin to air 118 days from
that date if hbo does the same thing for
house of the dragon as they did for game
of thrones then we could see the first
episode air somewhere around january
31st january 31st would be 118 days
after october 5th when that first teaser
was uploaded now since january 31st
falls on a monday and hbo likes to
release game of thrones episodes on
sundays i think january 30th or february
6 makes a lot more sense based on what
they did for game of thrones we should
see the first episode of house of the
dragon no later than february 6 which is
less than four months away
now i hope all of this actually makes
sense because i did throw a lot of
numbers at you i still have a feeling we
won't see house of the dragon until
april because that's when hbo would
always release game of thrones but i
also will not be shocked if we do see it
sooner considering they have already
given us a teaser trailer i guess we
shall see soon enough let me know when
you think we will see the first season
of house of the dragon do you think it
will release in april like most a game
of thrones seasons have before or do you
think the math adds up and maybe we have
less than 118 days before it airs on hbo
max i'm always interested in hearing
what you have to say
as always i want to thank all of you for
watching the video have a great day
everyone i will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
so
you